what is the best part about motherhood
right now Rihanna oh my God the
morning's just like seeing his morning
face yeah and you know like seeing a
baby with like little bags and waking up
and they're just like startled they're
trying to figure out where they at is
the cutest it's my favorite part of the
day the morning being a mom is
everything to Brianna and now the singer
explains why she's fiercely protective
of her nine-month-old son especially
when it comes to the paparazzi oh my God
the craziest stuff ree opens up to
British Vogue about the paps after her
March cover shoot which features re her
man ASAP Rocky and their little one was
interrupted by photographers on the
beach in December Point Blank ree says
it's the thing you never want to happen
the Grammy winner understands interest
in her son whose name has yet to be
revealed is Sky High but she wants to
introduce him to the World on her own
terms quote we get to decide as parents
when and how we do that end of story and
when it comes to the paparazzi ree says
they can take all the pics they want of
her but not her son he doesn't have a
say in any of this we've been protecting
him thus far and you don't have any
consent to be posting photos or selling
photos of my child a minor get the hell
out of here with that it really shocks
me as for those paps on the beach ree
says she went straight into protective
mode adding there wasn't even time for
rage but it did feel icky like a
violation that's when ree decided to
join Tick Tock and share this adorable
first look at her son in the car beating
the paps at their own game
oh
since giving birth to her little one
back in May the Grammy winners made it
clear to E.T she loves being a mom it
really feels Like A lot's happening all
at once I'm still pinching myself really
I'm grateful I'm grateful
and over the weekend the singer revealed
she's expecting baby number two during
Apple music's Super Bowl halftime show
she opens up to the mag about those
first few days home after giving birth
calling it simply nuts and she felt like
a zombie from the lack of sleep that's
amazing he's a happy baby but Reese says
despite all that being a mom is
everything you really don't remember
life before the feeling the desires the
things that you enjoy everything you
just don't identify with it because it
doesn't matter
foreign
[Music]